do you think that women who voted for
Hillary woman who have strongly
supported the feminist movement and
supported the left are feeling
disenfranchised given the current
climate of sexual brutality and
oppression brought to light in Hollywood
recently so I think that people have a
willingness to blind themselves to facts
that they don't want to see and so what
I've seen a lot is people saying well
the problem of sexual harassment isn't
unique to Hollywood and has nothing to
do with our culture regarding sex a
leftist culture regarding sex no it has
to do generally with men right it has to
do generally with American society it
has to do generally with power
relationships it's funny how everybody
is willing to generalize as soon as
they're ox is gored right as soon as as
soon as the left sees weight our culture
our feminist culture that we said that
we were gonna promulgate was gonna
protect women hasn't protected women you
know nearly at all then all of a sudden
it turns into well it's not us that's in
it's men that's in right and and so I've
been getting a lot of this online in the
last couple of days it's it's you men
who haven't stood up and I keep saying
like what do you want me to do and I'll
do it really what do you want me to do
like if you show me a rapist like Harvey
Weinstein allegedly is then I will say
send him to jail or castrate him right
like this is not difficult but if you
just say to me
you don't acknowledge the rape culture
again I need you to define that and I
need you to explain to me what I did I
think really I knew anything and I think
the vast majority of people in this room
didn't do anything and if they did do
something that maybe people should
report it to the police because that
seems to me the best way to root out
evil is to actually have law enforcement
get involved so the left is the question
of what the left is doing about this do
they feel disenfranchised no I think
they're just gonna blame the same people
they always blamed because we're all in
our own little bubbles should they feel
disenfranchised 100 percent because in a
society that treats sex is transactional
in a society that basically reduces sex
to any sort just a physical transaction
that is based solely on consent it makes
it very difficult to explain why it is
that the casting couch in Hollywood is
bad per se right there's actually like a
feminist theory says that it's bad
because of power imbalances but the sort
of libertarian culture of left suggests
that power imbalance doesn't have
anything to do with it if I feel like
trading my body for a part in a movie
well that's my business
and if you say differently than your
slut-shaming me right so that's it well
you can't really have it both ways
either it's
it's not bad and if we are going to
fight sexual harassment and sexual
assault it seems to me that we have to
do a couple of things one we have to
reinvest sex with value beyond just a
physical transaction it's not just two
people who are getting each other's
rocks off it actually means something
beyond that there's a relationship
that's attached to it and beyond that I
think that we need to re-encode Kate in
men themselves not just the teach men
not to rape routine like again it's such
a weird concept like when I was 11 my
dad didn't sit me down and say son don't
rape people like if you have to teach
your child that my guess is that you got
a bigger problem than that on your hands
what my dad taught me was to be a
gentleman and to treat women with
respect and that has to do with being a
gentleman and recognizing differences in
sex roles because one of the things
that's happened is the traditional
masculinity the idea that it is a man's
job to protect women this is one of our
jobs as human beings as men to protect
women the feminist movement doesn't like
that well then you can't blame us for
not protecting women if you don't want
us to protect women like I want to
protect women I think men should protect
women I think one of the reasons God put
man on earth is to protect women ok well
then it is incumbent on me to protect
women but if you're telling me that I
can't even open a door for a woman
because this is somehow an offense to
her honor and then if I say that it's
man's job to protect women that this is
somehow reinforcing gender stereotypes
then don't come whining to me when bad
stuff happens because the answer to bad
behavior is good behavior the answer to
vice is virtue the answer device isn't
just yelling and hashtagging crap
[Applause]